kobe goes straight to the dribble in the
lane later
what is average tonight you would think
his averages
will be with it now lakers lead 105.96
another three four away from elgin
baylor's laker record
[Applause]
well they're 70.
[Applause]
oh my goodness i see your point though
kobe down the middle
second 27 in the third
i see it here's number one do you
believe it
this one would be to tie wilt for number
two and the next one would be to pass
[Applause]
[Music]
55 in the second half ladies and
gentlemen you will be bryant against
christie kobe bryant on the move against
christie in for the right flips his shot
up no good o'neal lays it up missed it
ball tipped out to orion straight on
three good the lakers have won robert
[Applause]
portland has three timeouts left the
lakers have two
[Applause]
[Music]
back from the brink of elimination to
the brink of the nba finals
shaq waited as long as he possibly could
on the day
finally the fact cut rob the athleticism
the exuberance
that's why he's the mvp that's what the
mvp is all about
[Applause]
walton can tip it bryant with the save
shot here final seconds
bryant for the winning
[Applause]
nba champions
[Applause]
all right thanks bob kobe the other
night you had a dream
and it happened to come through tonight
to come through tonight i've already
made some big shots foxy the big three
and we won the game no feeling quite
like this isn't it i love it i can't
wait to do it again
all right congratulations kobe let's go
back to bob
[Applause]
from a minute
points
now you talk about a dagger that's a
dagger in the heart
[Music]
the lakers have won
back to back nba championships
and their 16th overall
the streamers are coming down from up
above the confetti falling on the floor
back-to-back titles and they get to do
it on their home floor in front of an
adoring crowd
[Applause]
[Music]
how about one minute what are you doing
and the next one is like great shot
what a tough tough play
they did a great job of forcing kobe
bryant to take a difficult shot and then
one or two
knees
that's 59 yeah they're going to leave
him in for 60. yeah they'll get a chance
to get it back to shot kobe underneath
gives the shot shot
oh man
points
outside jumper no good rebound is shot
jack's got 21. he's driven the ball he
knows what's going on in his 28th
birthday end of the kobe shaq gets the
assist and kobe makes a spectacular
underneath
117-97
[Music]
they're going to take shaq out the next
dead ball and shaq is pooped
happy birthday
[Music]
kobe comes over and plants a chick with
a big a kiss and the big guy's cheating
look at that bench they love him
and well they should
he that's his look
and that's where he's been scoring this
year oh turn back the clock there to
block trevor booker
and desperate to get to the basket and
score and he does
the week
qb and i anxiously await the email to
find out where we're flying kobe nice
number two
while they're playing some there's no
doubt about it talent he's got a lot of
bounce a lot of energy every night he
gives him a strong move nobody to the
basket oh pretty and one
50 50 guy getting everything that's
loose
kobe
oh
boy four in a row for bryant after
missing his first five 29 years old
roxanna look at kobe keeping the ball
feeling it
firing oh got them all
this is like old times now
hall of famer shaquille o'neal
well you know brian on the drive nice
anytime he's gone in the basket tonight
mikey's he's been able to blow right by
the defender free throws to tie the game
and then the lakers gave a foul kobe
came out here he is for three nice
that was a dagger that's the old pov
where we went to germany for the blood
drink you know the circulation of the
blood then the elbow all right then the
bad finger
and then the shoulder
hayward staying right with him
bryant scores anyway
you see remember what jack said when
lisa interviewed him
couldn't get the role in the three but
he's gonna have another shot at
to the basket kobe
they wanted a dunk though yeah they're
happy with the hoop
[Music]
bryant on the drive to the basket hangs
and score there you go
[Applause]
terrific
journalist for nba.com
[Music]
kobe baseline uber neto has 32
out of his
1346 games so just under a third
hits the three
[Applause]
35. really was very instrumental on who
was coming here
going to the basket
37 for bryant
come on now you got to get a score here
work this is seeking kobe for
yes
see he said hey up i heard the three for
16. in the other obviously the size of
the league impacting that
jordan didn't do it against the bulls
ryan here hits another three
43.
we have nine players from brazil this
year i think that would surprise a lot
of people
45
he and kobe have a very special unique
bond
brian gibbs to the basket and has 47
points let's see if he gets 50 here
bryant
going to the basket
hey bryant there it is a 50-point game
in his farewell
final minute 30. bryant from 14 has 53
[Applause]
unbelievable stuff tonight
kobe's got the lakers last check
ryan 4-3
[Applause]
the lakers down one
will kobe give them one last gamer
bryant
on the move with the jumper
58 points
and the lakers lead